for those that don't know what's
happening with you and your son you want
to give us the the 101 sure so um
starting about two years old my ex-wife
decided to transition my son to a girl
we were still married at the time and I
told her she couldn't do that she's a
pediatrician and she uh forced me out of
my house filed for divorce and then
began to really in Earnest try to
transition my son she began to present
him to the world as a girl she changed
his name without my consent with no
legal basis to do that my son eventually
at three years old we're still heading
towards divorce tells me that mommy says
I'm a girl so I took the first iPhone
video I'd ever taken
and if you go on YouTube you can find it
just search for mommy says I'm a girl it
went everywhere I'm an Orthodox
Christian
so it also went all over Eastern Europe
and Russian television got a hold of it
they were all perplexed like they think
of the Texas as a Bible Belt how could
it be how can this be happening in this
religious part of the country so then we
get to trial
um the psychology Community turned
completely against me all of them lied
at trial so far I've been able to prove
all these psychologists have lied so all
their testimonies been thrown out what
were they lying about whether my son
wants to be a girl or a boy in in the
initial uh psychological investigation
they tried to cover for my wife by
saying she wasn't trying to transition
my son
and on that basis that I had made a
false accusation that she was trying to
transition him gave me less than
Standard Possession time with my son
so then we go to another trial in 2019
after the school started transitioning
my son behind my back
so I take my son to school and in boys
clothes they give him a dress make him
use the the girls restroom and it turns
out there's a loophole in all the 50
states around psychology that allows
psychologists to not inform parents
parents actually don't have a legal
right to the medical and psychological
records of their children I can explain
that later
so they they use that law to transition
by some without my consent I found out
about it I filed grievances with the
school district they said they did not
violate my parental rights by
transitioning my son without my consent
so we wound up going to a 2019 trial
in this little courthouse in Dallas
Texas and the top experts in the world
on transgender science from both sides
showed up in this courtroom only my
experts testified because the
depositions that I gave the experts on
the other side was so devastating they
would never put them in front of a Texas
jury I'll give you an example Johanna
Olson Kennedy who runs the largest
gender clinic in the United States
I directly asked her how do you justify
cutting healthy body parts off of
children
and she said well it if they're if
they're causing psychological distress
they're not they're not healthy body
parts so we cut them off
I asked how many total mastectomies have
you referred out for pubescent girls and
she said over 250.
so they didn't want to put that in front
how many hens and feet did they chop off
of boxes body dysmorphic people yeah
exactly well Joanna Olson Kennedy also
said that um if peop if if girls end up
wanting to have their breasts back they
can just get fake ones yeah she did she
did so so but let's let's go back to the
beginning I mean how does how does this
begin how did your wife
decide that your son in her mind why is
she saying that your son is actually
trans well I first noticed it when she
would put him into timeouts and she'd
say things like you know don't be a boy
the monsters only eat boys and weird
stuff like this oh yeah what yes oh yes
but why is she doing it but she
testified in court to this this is what
she's testified I don't believe this
answer but I'm going to tell you what
she swore to in front of the judge at
the 2019 trial she said first James
asked for a girl's meal in a McDonald's
Happy Meal the girl's toy in a
McDonald's Happy Meal second a few days
later he asked for a silver purse at
Target that had a multi-colored unicorn
on it and James is a painter he's still
a painter and so he wanted this purse
and at that point she thought he might
be a girl that's what she testified to
because he liked the unicorns I don't
believe it he's like unicorns yeah I
mean I used to pretend I was Wonder
Woman I would dance around in my
backyard Swinging The Invisible whip
because I wanted to be an actor because
I'm creative and my parents had freaked
out and been like maybe that means like
no you're a creative yes you can pretend
to be anybody anything yes you can yeah
and children will conform themselves to
their parents wishes and all sorts of
ways and my son has told court-appointed
psychologists four of them
that the reason that he here's the other
fact that's really important for you and
your audience to know my son only
presents as a girl with his mom he's
never presented as a girl with me or
anywhere else at church or anywhere it's
only when he's with his mom that he does
this
so he's just told them straight up mommy
doesn't love me if I'm not a girl he's
told him that over and over again told
the judge that told the court appointed
psychologist
um what happened they they all
recommended that he be transitioned to a
girl all of them
I mommy doesn't love me if I'm not a
girl this is what he said yes that's
that's like what has that implicates the
mother I know what precipitated me
losing my son's all contact with my sons
um last year in July
was my son just straight up told the the
his counselor that he doesn't want to be
a girl he's getting embarrassed wearing
dresses at school
she didn't uh even acknowledge that he
said it
so he had an Apple Watch and he recorded
himself he said I'm going to record
telling you this
and your son did yes and she totally
freaked out threw him out of the office
and initiated a CPS investigation
against me
and told the the court that I had forced
him to say that
how old is your son how old is your son
now 10. 10 he was nine when he said that
yeah did you force him to do it no no he
did ask me if he could record and I said
Texas is a one-party recording state but
our family's not sneaky so if you're
going to record people you should tell
them that you're recording them so just
tell her that you're going to record her
so so where is it where where where's
the story currently at now he's uh your
wife ex-wife took him to California the
judge uh allowed her to move to
California uh she doesn't have to tell
me where my sons are
so all I know is that they're in LA
county the only way for me to see my
sons is to arrange for supervised visits
in LA County
okay
um and it has to be someone that's
acceptable to the court
so the judge will be able to pick who
that is no matter who I pick they won't
let me do it
um she doesn't have to tell me any
medical procedures that she's doing she
doesn't have to tell me where they go to
school I'm actually prohibited from even
knowing those things wow yeah so I
haven't seen him in about a year and six
months now why both like who are so two
kids you said one's ten and then one
they're both ten they're twins yep and
they're not identical and so she's
saying one is and one is not trans yeah
and this is something that she did with
her daughters
so so if you want to know like when I
when I realized I was in trouble
it was during her pregnancy
we made a decision to have children
we're about two and a half years out of
the marriage and I discover everything
she told me about her daughters was a
lie
so uh she had told me that her daughters
were adopted
well
her younger daughter was adopted from
her brother who's a three-time convicted
felon in California had to flee the
state because he was convicted again
he'll get life who exposed this child to
methamphetamine in the womb and and knew
when she was a newborn and had all these
developmental problems so I didn't know
that I probably would have still married
and
um knowing that right because it's good
to adopt orphans like that I'm all for
that but her other daughter was from a
sperm donor and I would not have married
or had I known that why not why not well
it it was it would be like she wants to
have kids without that without a man
without a father interesting yeah and
both of the girls I didn't know this
either both uh Ann's sister is a lesbian
and both of these girls had been raised
only around women like I remember
um going out and running you know foot
races with the girls
because she basically abandoned her
girls to me so like I am the one who had
to take them to school do all their
homework
you know uh everything all the chores in
the house she worked 80 hours a week at
her practice right and so I got got
these girls that I had to raise so we go
out and run foot races and stuff like
that and they just couldn't believe that
I was winning
like they they didn't know like boys can
run faster than girls wow they just had
not been around any men
and um and thought that was actually
very funny that they were learning that
and didn't know that but they were 10
years old and is just discovering that
for the first time sounds a lot like
that book that we bring up periodically
the one that's in front of you yeah
genderqueer yeah yeah have you uh have
you read that one I have not read it I
haven't heard about it I bought a copy
of that and read it myself yeah yeah
it's a story of how this uh this uh this
woman is not she said she's non-binary
but it's an abuse story yeah I couldn't
read till she was 12. yep she had to use
old crusted pads with blood flaking off
and she smelled so bad because of it the
counselor called her in and said you
have a hygiene problem so it's no wonder
she ends up of course you know
distressed well and the book ends like
the the most triumphant part of the book
is when she's deciding that she's going
to come out to her middle school class
yeah and like tell all of her students
that she's which is non-binary which is
like why do we need to why does anyone
need to do that why do these people want
to be about around children so so much
is odd it's odd and sort of distressing
yeah but so so so you're I I remember
when the the story first broke about the
court case and the videos with your son
and all that stuff but your son's 10 now
I mean 10 year olds have a decent amount
of of you know Lucidity so is is he
resisting is he rejecting this is he
complaining about it well the remember
the last time I saw him was when he
resisted and they took him away from me
permanently and gave me supervised
visitation I get less visitation than
convicted pedophiles in Texas you know
what's crazy too though it's early on in
the story I remember reading in the
Federalist there was
um a woman who was the mom of some
friends of your son who said that when
he was over at her house he wanted to
wear boy clothes and she like gave him
boy clothes and he just wanted to do
Rough and Tumble boy things that's his
normal State and her testimony she was
not allowed to testify to that no she
wasn't they they wouldn't let her why
would they take her peace why
um I don't know why they wouldn't let
her do it but they wouldn't they
wouldn't accept her yeah thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time